Las Vegas gearing up getting ready to
count down to 2023 preparations unveiled
today for the big New Year's Eve bash
yeah so of course as usual a lot of
major roads are going to be closed in
and around the strip and that's going to
impact traffic Joshua peguero shares the
plans
road closures will begin on Saturday at
around six with about 4 000 metal
barricades placed at several spots along
the strip to control vehicle and
pedestrian traffic expect closures at
the Spring Mountain ramps all the way to
Tropicana ramps by 8 PM no vehicles on
the Strip Clark County Commissioner Jim
Gibson says safety is important and the
barricades should control crowds we
insert them in the intersections
principally because the the thing we're
concerned about is is vehicular traffic
there with all the people in the roadway
400 000 visitors are expected to ring in
the New Year in Las Vegas the company
switches housing the command center for
law enforcement assistant Sheriff Andrew
Walsh says Metro will be out in full
force we take a look at events that
happen across the globe not just here in
the United States and look for all the
different ways especially some of these
things that we've seen are very
unsophisticated in style you know a
vehicle into a crowd doesn't take a lot
of forth order planning and with weather
concerns Saturday night commissioner
Gibson says there are contingency plans
we imagine we'll be able to pull it off
but it is the win more than anything the
rain is something that can make it
miserable out there on Las Vegas
boulevards after the fireworks show
there will be about 16 street sweepers
out on the Strip cleaning about 12 tons
of trash Josh bruguero eight news now